[Music]
let's go to gainesville georgia
incidentally george where i started my
radio career w-d-u-n was the radio
station where i started out so i love
gainesville georgia ashton joins us
there ashton how can we help
hey i just wanted to say first and
foremost i'm a huge fan i've been
listening since i was in high school wow
um and i've been following uh
for the past five years because i
graduated 2016 has uh
been doing my dave-ish
plan and i have
recently just
come to realize that dave ish doesn't
work and it's all or nothing
and um so with that i have a huge
question i'm currently in baby step two
and i'm also
cash flowing my way through school
no student loans or anything but i do
have just shy of 20 grand in debt
um with a household income of right
under 40k i want to say it's like 39.5
is what right about what i bring in what
kind of debt is the 20 grand
so 10 3 of it is a car loan and then the
rest of it is just multiple credit cards
kind of spread out
between different credit cards
and my
big question with that is
do i need to put a hold on school to
finish baby step two
or do i finish cash flowing my way
through
in this degree that i started as uh i'm
not even sure if this is the field i
want to go in or
okay not i'm not sure
so all right so let's press pause on the
on the uh money question and because i
think this is going to tie in if you're
not entirely sure i want to know what
you percentage you would put on it right
now is it 50 50 is it 80 20 70 30 as to
how sure you are that this degree you're
in right now is not the direction you
want to go
hit me straight as far as
as far as
it's a business management degree that
i'm working on right now
and as far as percentage wise and
everything like that goes i'm looking at
like i'm like
70 30
70 30. not pursuing that direction
the 30 would be in the not the 70 is in
the end uh as far as pursuing
so he's leaning towards a yes oh you're
okay i i confused myself here you are
leaning towards moving into business
management type work
correct it's really just a
with how broad of an umbrella the degree
is and everything like that i'm not sure
where specifically and there i want to
go i do have about a about 14 months
yeah of management experience that
shifts leading count
hey ashton i gotta tell you right now i
would press pause on cash flowing to
school and i'd crush the debt because
i'm gonna tell you right now
uh you don't need a degree to get into
business management you already said you
got 14 months of experience leading
you know
you could go get a job two jobs
increase your income which gets you out
of debt faster and get in a situation
where you're following somebody and
there's an opportunity there's a ladder
there for you to step up into leadership
you don't need a degree to get into
leadership
so i would press pause there's just too
much unknowns right now for you to be
taking that valuable cash
and cash flowing a super general degree
for sure the only reason that i uh that
i have that experience i've been working
uh in the food business for a while um
and everything and
i uh my fiance and i welcomed our son
into the world back in 2019
and i
jumped up uh you know jumped up the
chain just a little bit just to bring in
a little extra money but that
jump forward put me in a bind on the
family end
and every schedule
it felt like it drove a wedge
into that and everything and so it was
like it was like i was doing my calling
but in the wrong
area and i don't know quite where that
area is okay we're going to lock in
we're going to lock in right here ashton
you just led to it
you felt like you were doing your
calling but in the wrong place i like to
call that you're doing the right thing
in the wrong place i'm guessing the
hours in the food service industry and
all that was just crushing the
relationship i get that uh because you
got a little one now
so is leading and managing people that's
what you love to do
that yes okay so so hold on
hold on i want you to focus on something
very clearly
if you can lead people and manage people
and develop people
help them win in the food industry can
you not do the same thing in other
industries
yes or no for sure
for sure i like that answer george
confident all right so george let's now
so here's the deal ash i'm gonna turn
you over to george i want you to press
pause on this degree right now i'm not
saying don't go back and finish it but
i'm saying you can move up
professionally even now
because you've got leadership experience
he's got 20 grand to pay off george yeah
at this point is your fiance working
she is
1400 a month and that's on top of the 40
that you're bringing in a year
correct okay well if either of you can
get a second job i want to tackle this
thing if you're going to pause school
then we need to go really hard at this
debt if you're going to continue school
i'd say all right well continue through
school cash flow that and then tackle
this debt as soon as you graduate but if
we're pausing school we've gotta get
gotta get rid of this debt i mean this
is half of your income tied up in credit
cards and car loans maybe see how much
the car is worth you can drive a beater
for a while and get this debt uh payoff
cut in half i'm all for that and here's
the deal they're gonna knock out the 20
grand pretty quick school will still be
there
okay but this is the greatest priority
and i think it's going to put some
attention on how i can get where i want
to get
minus the degree and leading people
well you don't have to have a degree to
lead people come on get after it young
man your future is
waiting for you